so here we have a a set of parametric
equations where x and y are both defined
in terms of t so if you input all the
possible ts that you can into these
functions and then plot the
corresponding x and y's for each chord
for each t this will plot a curve in the
x y plane what i want to do in this
video is figure out the first derivative
of y with respect to x and the second
derivative of y with respect to x and in
both cases it's going to be in terms of
t so let's let's get to it so first
let's find the first derivative of y
with respect to x
first derivative of y with respect to x
and we've seen this before
in other videos where this is going to
be the derivative of y with respect to t
over the derivative of x
with respect to t
and so this is going to be equal to
well what is the derivative of y with
respect to t
d y
d t
is equal to
let's see the derivative of e to the 3t
with respect to 3t is just e to the 3t
and then the derivative of 3t with
respect to t
is going to be 3. so i could say times 3
like that or i could put that 3 out
front and then the derivative of
negative 1 well negative a constant
doesn't change no matter what you do
with to your t so that's just going to
be zero so that's d y d t so it's going
to be equal to three
e
to the
three
t
all of that over well what's the
derivative of x with respect to t
derivative of x with respect to t is
equal to
well we're going to have the 3 out front
and so the derivative of e to the 2t
with respect to 2t
is going to be e to the 2t
and then we're going to take the
derivative of 2t with respect to t which
is just 2. so this is going to be 6 e to
the 2t
e
to the
6e to the 2t and let's see we could
simplify this a little bit
i'll now go to a neutral color
this is equal to
so e to the so this is going to be one
half that's 3 over 6.
e
to the
three t minus two t
three t minus two t and i'm just using
exponent properties right over here but
three if i have three t's and i take
away two of those t's i'm just gonna
have a t
so
this is just going to simplify to a t
right over here
so now that we know the we we've now
figured out the the first derivative of
y with respect to x in terms of t now
how do we find the second derivative how
do we find the second derivative of y
with respect
with respect to
x now and i'll give you a hint we're
going to use this same idea if you want
to find the rate of change of something
with respect to x you find the rate of
change of that something with respect to
t and divide it by the rate of change of
x with respect to t
so what this is going to be
this is going to be we want to find the
derivative of the first derivative with
respect to t so let me write this down
so we want to find
we want to take the derivative with
respect to t in the numerator
of the first derivative
which i will put in blue now of d y
d x
all of that over
the all of that over d x
d x
d t
now i want you to if it didn't if it
doesn't jump out at you why this might
why this is the same thing that we did
before i encourage you to pause the
video and think about it think about
what we did over here the first time
when we finally wanted to find the
derivative of y with respect to
x
we found the derivative of y with
respect to t
and then divided that by the derivative
of x with respect to t
here we want to find the derivative we
want to find the second derivative of y
with respect to x actually let me just
write it down out here a little bit
clearer what we really want to do is we
want to find the derivative with respect
let me write it this way
when we wanted to find the derivative
with respect to x
of
y
that was equal to
derivative of y with respect to t over
the derivative of x with respect to t
now we want to find the derivative
with respect to x
of
the first derivative with respect to x
and so everywhere we saw a y here
replace that with the first derivative
so this is going to be equal to
in the numerator the derivative with
respect to t
of
d y
dx
notice this was derivative with respect
to t of y
in fact let me write it that way just so
you can see it so if i clear this out
so if i clear that out we're going to
get
this is the derivative with respect to t
of
y
so hopefully you see
before we had a y there now
we have a d y d x
d x d t
now this might seem really daunting and
complicated except for the fact that
these are actually fairly straight
things to evaluate if the of taking the
derivative with respect to t of the
first derivative well that's just taking
the derivative with respect to t of this
and this is pretty easy this is the
derivative was just going to be one half
and the derivative with respect to t of
e to the t is just e to the t
and so that's going to be over the
derivative of x with respect to t which
we already saw is 6e to the 2t
e
to the 2t
and so we can write this
we can write this as
let's see one half divided by 6 is 1
over 12 and then e
to the t minus 2t
which is equal to
we could write this as 1 12
e to the negative t
or we could write this as 1 over
e
to the t and we're done